the rust mo one solar power plant lies
just across the road from one of South
Africa's platinum mines mining
operations like this one are making
South Africa one of the world's most
power-hungry economies but it's being
fed by an aging and increasingly
unreliable batch of coal-fired power
plants that struggle to supply almost
ninety percent of the country's
electricity needs the result has been
frequent power outages independently run
renewable energy projects like rust no
one are part of the government's power
procurement program to fill the gap this
is rust no one solar farm a seven
megawatt solar farm that consists of
over 29,000 solar modules and basically
produces energy from the Sun which far
underground cables is seen through to
our substation over here which converts
the electricity to supply to the
National Grid the program is widely seen
as a resounding success delivering
affordable clean and reliable energy to
consumers but recently the CEO of
state-owned power provider Eskom said
his company won't issue any more
contracts to independent producers
without first consulting with the
Department of Energy that's caused quite
a stir in the sector
the clash between Escamilla and
Department of Energy on the statement
released by Brandon levy in my humble
opinion effectively a power
consideration or concern where Eskom is
losing more and more of its generating
capacity to independent power producers
who are coming in quite cost-effectively
as compared to Eskom coal-fired power
stations and potentially the nuclear
power program although South Africa
currently only operates one nuclear
plant its government has proposed
constructing another three four or more
reactors it would be the largest
government tender in the country's
history and worth an estimated forty
billion to 120 billion euros it's
reported the government has already
signed binding agreements with Russian
nuclear power company Raza Tom but an
escomm spokesman says nuclear makes
financial sense well the the price of
nuclear is still way below what the
renewable energy projects are selling at
currently within our fleet actually
nucleus the cheapest we're producing
power at about ten cents per kilowatt
hour and basically the renewables are
still less than to rain so still
obviously the difference is very big day
Gareth Warner doubts those figures and
he's skeptical of South Africa's nuclear
ambitions which are shrouded in
allegations of corruption no nuclear
power will never be cheaper than
renewable energy particularly solar and
wind plus we have exposed it'll take a
ten year build cycle where as a
renewable energy project will take one
to two years to build and you've got
exposure of the south african rand
against the euro or the dollar over a
ten-year period so no one can even
project the cost of actually what will
cost to build a nuclear power nuclear
power plant the move away from solar
power towards the costly dream of cheap
nuclear energy might well turn into a
financial nightmare for South Africa
many observers claim the change has the
power to bankrupt the country
you